avec une ferveur unique en france
l'alsace toute entière se prépare à
célébrer joyeusement la nativité noël en
alsace c'est sacré saviez vous que
certains symboles de noël sont nés dans
cette région à commencer par le sapin de
noël sans sapin au 16e siècle
parallèlement à d'autres provinces
germanique l'alsace choisi cet arbre
pour marquer la fête de noël
le rpf évoqué cette magie du sapin dans
cette archive de 1966 noël et la noël
que ponctuent l'arbre toujours vers
apportant avec lui au fond de chaque
homme ces effluves de résine et je ne
sais quelle pureté descendu tout droit
des montagnes des sapins vendus à
strasbourg au fameux marché de noël un
marché qui lui aussi est une très
vieille tradition depuis quand déjà
depuis longtemps ça ne sait pas depuis
combien
depuis 1570 très exactement à l'époque
strasbourg est un bastion du
protestantisme pour se démarquer des
catholiques
la municipalité lance le marché de
l'enfant jésus
ça se dit crij kindle ce méric en
alsacien les strasbourgeois m6 promet
depuis des générations nous mais c'est
pourquoi je continue à beaucoup prendre
l'ambiance on ne peut pas faire les
achats de noël sans passer par le cash
mais ça fait partie au marché de noël
on trouve de nombreuses gourmandises
comme les bredele les traditionnels
gâteaux de noël d'alsace n'est pas chaud
en 1992 strasbourg s'autoproclame
capitale de noël le marché s'agrandit
considérablement la tradition aux
origines religieuses devient un atout
commercial de taille pour la ville et sa
région
très vite le succès commercial est au
rendez vous encore confidentielle il ya
quatre ans le plus vieux marché de noël
de france attire aujourd'hui des
milliers de français d'allemands de
suisse et de belges un résultat dû à la
promotion de strasbourg capitale de noël
dans toute l'europe
c'est la reconnaissance d'une ville et
d'une région au coeur de la symbolique
de l'ol
tommy north
[Musique]